thank you uh good afternoon members
uh officers and uh welcome to this
planning committee meeting
on wednesday the 16th of december 2020
um as usual i will read through the
names that i have on my list
there is a couple of changes of our
committee since
we last met again i am aware there is
an apology which i will come to under
that agenda item
so if i can go go through your names and
i can see most
people are here but if you could answer
me please
um counselor common cook
here chair counselor steve woburn
yeah here chair council joel bayford
here chair councillor alan curry
here chair councillor john dennis
councillor pat moore
no uh counselor becky wing
he chair i'm sub for mike yes thank you
uh becky um
councillor david hart here jett
uh councillor heather keane here chair
counselor paul moore
here chair uh councilman matthew
scott i believe he's going to be a
little bit late because of his work
um i'll come back to that councillor
gary taylor
i think gary is the same with his post
office role
counseling the right here chair
and myself obviously i'm here thank you
right as usual a few notes for
yourselves um
if you have technical decrees during a
meeting then
please contact them at democratic
services
which is james today on 507
200 and it will be included
in the chat box on your right hand side
for your
convenience i would ask participants to
mute their microphones when you are not
speaking
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone
who is listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on for the
participant to speak
when they've got permission to gain
permission to speak
please just note in the chat box
or use the hand which is on
our screens and i think we all know how
to use that now
uh once you have finished speaking
please turn your microphones to mute
but everybody please present to please
ensure that their mobile phones are
turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls once the meet is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
and conducting other business and ensure
that you are in a quiet room free from
distractions for the duration of this
meeting i will remind you that
this meeting is being live streamed for
members of the public
to watch if they wish and following the
meeting
the recording will be available on the
council's
youtube channel
members requesting to speak under 20.1
do we have any members who i can't see
um who are online who wish to speak on
any item
okay thank you uh so agenda item
one apologies for absence
um as we mentioned i do have apologies
from councillor ghana
who is substituted today by councillor
wing
i've also received apologies from
councillor john dennis are there any
other apologies
no okay thank you the gender item
two are there any declarations of
interest
no agenda item three
approving the minutes uh do members
agree that the minutes the planning
committee
meeting held on the 18th of november
be approved and signed by the chairman
can i have a proposal please i'll
propose that chair councillor alban
council robin thank you a second please
oh second that chair councillor common
cook
thank you councillor coleman cook the
members agree
rude okay thank you agree
yep i won't go through names on there
again thank you
agenda item four schedule of planning
applications and public speaking
uh once again members i'm sure you're
aware of this we still
and looking at the future sadly we
we cannot have site visits because of
the covid
regulations the following application
has been reserved for public speaking
and that is agenda item 4a
which is 21 belmont road ramsgate
so moving on to that agenda item 4a
as i've mentioned the address i will ask
the officer now to read out a public
speaking
statement who is in favor of this
application
asuki if you wouldn't mind please thank
you chair
the most important consideration to take
into account is the fact that planning
consent is only required for this change
of use as a result of the council's
imposition
of an article for direction which was
removed which has removed the right to
change the use of a property in sanit
from a single dwelling to a small hmo
for occupation by up to six
persons as with all government
legislation
including all amendments to permitted
development rights
the government undertook an impact
assessment to determine
whether it was desirable appropriate and
acceptable
to introduce this particular permitted
development right
its decision to do so therefore confirms
that it is the government's view
that the change of use of a property
from a single dwelling to a small
hmo for occupation by up to six persons
regardless of the type or location of
property
would not have such an impact upon the
local area
as to justify requiring planning consent
the primary aim of the council's article
4 direction was therefore to address
the issue of concentration whereby the
uncontrolled proliferation of small hmos
particularly in areas of pre-existing
intensity
would be likely to adversely affect the
character and residential amenity of an
area
which had previously been recognized in
the case of part of cliftonville which
contributed
to the formulation and adoption of the
cliftonville development plan
and the subsequent adopted policy in the
current local plan
to prevent the further increase in the
number of hmos in both the cliftonville
west
and margate central waltz it is
therefore considered that
far greater weight should be given to
the matter of concentration of hmos
rather than upon perceived impact upon
an area
by a single small hmo when government
has concluded that
such a use should not by virtue of its
limited scale
be likely to create unacceptable amenity
or highway-related effects
notwithstanding this point officers have
concluded that in this instance
the proposed scale of the proposal
namely occupation by four
unrelated adults would be little
different to occupation of the property
by two parents and two children
in terms of noise disturbance refuge
storage needs
and vehicle ownership especially if the
children were aged
17 or over and given the lesser
likelihood
of vehicle ownership by the intended
occupiers of the hmo
indeed planning inspectors have
consistently found
in determining appeals that there is no
reason to assume that
occupiers of an hmo are more likely to
be responsible for antisocial behavior
the applicant therefore commends the
officer report and recommendation to
members
who are respectfully asked to give
favorable consideration
to this application
thank you very much tsuki uh i've asked
our planning officer which i believe is
in this afternoon um
if you agreed out the report please
thank you chairman um i will just
program my screen
uh
okay so the application site is uh
is outlined in red on the screen so the
application here as mentioned in the
statement
is to change the use of this dwelling
which is under the use class c3
to use class c4 which is
which as stated covers small hmos
between
three to six unrelated people um i don't
necessarily have anything to add with
regards to the history of
why it needs planning permission over
and above the statement uh which
provided a summary
um but because the application does
require planning permission by virtue of
the
article 4 direction that the council
placed on the urban
area with regards to hmos um it falls to
consider its application against
the statutory development plan and in
this instance that's policy
h ho
which talks about hmos which is outlined
in the report
so just looking at the the site on the
slide
um so it's on this property is on
belmont road
it's a terrorist property within a row
of of two-story
terrorist dwellings belmont road in
ramsgate
is this road here so it's just behind
asda then you've also got chatham street
here we've got actually the site that
members looked at not too long ago
just the north of belmont road here and
obviously the town center is just off
here with
the swimming pool over here in ramsgate
uh so this is the property in question
so it's a two-story property but you can
see there's actually
a basement level there as well which
forms part of the accommodation
um so um in terms of going through the
main issues
um so as i mentioned policy h019
um the considerations within that are
are sort of are
four-fold so one is the consideration of
whether or not
an hmo would have an unacceptable impact
on neighbouring properties
uh the second point is whether or not
there is an intensification or
concentration of
that type of use in the area to cause a
detriment to the character of the area
then there's a consideration with
regards to car parking
and then a consideration with regards to
storage and waste collection
um so as mentioned that policy applies
to all hmos so it does apply to
c4 hmos when planning information is
required as well as hmos up to
you know more than 10 people that's the
policy test that's considered
so in terms of the actual proposal
itself
so this is the existing layout of the
property
so you can see the the basement here uh
which has got the the window at the
front
then you've got the actual layout itself
at the moment which is
a lounge and dining room with a kitchen
at the rear
and then uh it's got three bedrooms
upstairs
with a bathroom as well and there's also
a shower room on the on the ground floor
so the proposal as it originally came in
was
for an hmo up to six unrelated
people um but it's been considered a
couple of times by
officers and subsequently amended on two
occasions down to five people and then
subsequently
upon further consideration down to four
people so the proposal is
to change the use uh to an hmo for
for unrelated people and there is a
proposed condition
on uh any approval which would restrict
it to
to four people and so you can see the
layout
as proposed here so you have a bedroom
at the front of the properties of the
ground floor is in the middle here
the middle plan you've got the
bedrooms at the the front and then uh
sort of to the back next to the
staircase and then with a living room
shower room
at the rear and then on the first floor
you have
a bedroom at the front and again a
bedroom so mirroring
what's on the ground floor with then uh
two separate bathrooms at the rear
and then there's a a kitchen and dining
room area
on the on the basement level again you
saw from the photo
the the fact that there is a sort of a
basement area
within the property with with the light
being provided at the front
um so in terms of going back to the
the location of the site it is
considered the site is
is sustainable in terms of its location
for for both residential occupancy at
the moment but also with the proposal
it's within walking distance of you know
very good bus links
walk very close distance from the town
centre and facilities
and not too far away from ramsgate
station as well
um in terms of those tests of um
of the hmo in terms of
unacceptable impact on living conditions
of neighbouring occupiers
as the proposal has been restricted to
four individuals
it's not considered to be a significant
number of
people over and above what a house of
this scale would normally have as a
residential
dwelling doesn't it doesn't increase uh
overly the the comings and goings
um in this street particularly in
comparison
if you've got terrorist properties that
are quite uh quite tight so there's
already
quite a bit of comings and goings and it
doesn't doesn't increase that
and there's no evidence to demonstrate
that this use these four people would
cause
more noise than a c3 dwelling house and
indeed this is a point that picked up by
the supportive statement
but that does indeed hold in uh appeal
decisions
uh that you know it's not there's no
demonstrable evidence to suggest that
these occupants would make more
more noise than those in a normal
dwelling house
in terms of the the second point about
concentration
um so there are no licensed hmos in
this road um the housing uh
team the the private sector housing team
have given a comment which is in the
report
um which confirms that when a license is
required so that's
for five people or more uh
they would have a log of where those
licenses are and
in this instance there aren't any in
belmont road
from looking through the planning
history of properties on belmond road
since the article 4 direction came in
we've had
no applications for any properties in
belmont road to change
their use to a c4 hmo
and so there's no evidence that there's
concentration
of this type of accommodation to change
the character of the area
uh within belmont road
in terms of highways um there
is um on-street parking on belmont road
but it is
heavily parked up as a road at the
moment um you can actually see it in the
image
that's there which is the satellite
image from from google
um so it's unrestricted at the moment
however that the site is as mentioned
is highly sustainable within walking
distance of the town center
and there is no justification that four
people in a property would result in
severe harm
to highway safety or indeed parking
immunity
over and above the existing lawful use
with
three bedrooms and whilst there are
clearly parking pressures in the
area um this change of use would not
result in a material effect
on the living conditions of residents by
virtue of the change over and above
it currently is um and with regards to
the fourth criteria which is about
storage
um of and waste collections
again it is it is predominantly almost
the same as existing um you know there
are terrace properties so it does
require
you know bin storage at the rear of the
property that then runs through the
house
but it's no different from any of the
other residential properties on the
on the road um so in conclusion the
development is considered to be in
accordance with uh policy agen 19
of the local plan uh and then subject
conditions including the restriction to
no more than four people um the
application is is recommended for
approval
uh thank you ian i move that the
officer's recommendation
is adopted could the vice chair please
second
oh second nature thank you council com
and cook i have a few
speakers here and thank you council
taylor uh for coming along i know you're
busy
um council uh more
paul moore please uh thank you chair um
unfortunately my question has been
answered by mr livingston
um and that was in as much as he's he's
stated that there will be a condition to
limit
to form the application so my query has
already been answered thank you
thank you very much uh cancer alban
yes thank you chair um
these are always difficult to share
these these type of applications
in relation to multiple occupancies it's
it's obviously clear
that small residential units like this
which have a small hmo use
are required um however the balance of
that is to
is to what uh what the effect would be
on surrounding areas um uh sorry on
surrounding
properties um could i just ask mr
levinson first
if is the property empty at the present
time
thank you um i i'm afraid to say i don't
actually i don't have that information
i'm afraid i don't know if it is vacant
or not whilst other questions are going
on i can see if there's anything in the
application form to indicate whether or
not it is or not but
but i'm afraid i don't i don't know i'm
afraid okay thank you
um as mr levinson has said
that there isn't any other licensed
uh multiple occupancies in belmont
road um and we've had no applications
uh within belmont road for multiple
occupancies
however we don't know if there's any
unauthorized
multiple occupancies in belmont road
um also um with
effectively four separate households
within a small property could result
in many visitors
to the property especially if they are
younger people who will be
who will be living there um and that
concerns me somewhat in relation to
the um adjoining properties
uh i see there were a number of um
uh objections to this application
uh by local residents in in the
report and um
and and i have to say that um
at the present time i'm i'm i'm a bit
unbalanced as to whether
as to where i go with this chair um i
do get what the officer's report says uh
that that we should go with this as an
approval but i do have reserve
reservations so before i decide what i'm
going to do i want to listen to what
other members have to say
thank you chair uh thank you councillor
allman councillor keane
thank you um i've got a couple of
questions i know you've said that there
are no other hmos in the road
but if this was agreed does it set a
precedent
i mean how do you decide when there's
too many hmos when there's too high a
concentration
that was my first um question and my
second was you say about it just being
limited to four people
but couldn't the rooms be occupied by
couples and then would they have to
leave two rooms empty
and who checks up on how many people are
actually living there
those are my questions thank you thank
you ian can you
answer those please yeah i can i can
come back on those so in terms of the
the point to do with
concentration so within policy
hn19 there is criteria which
talks about the number within particular
area
um which would define whether or not the
character is sort of
changing into into more
predominantly this type of accommodation
so in this instance
it would by granting permission it
wouldn't set a precedent
but obviously it would start almost the
the
uh the assessment of how many you know
could this road or this area
take and obviously this one would be one
that would be logged
as you know one that's already in place
and there and therefore it would
it would almost restrict the number that
could appear
by virtue of being being present um
in terms of the restriction on the
numbers
um the condition which is number number
three
in the in the in the recommendation
um is is effectively stating that no
more than four p
four persons can occupy the property as
their principal main residence now
you know obviously um that means
effectively they are
living at the property uh in terms of
checking that it's not something that's
periodically monitored when it comes to
um you know when it comes to planning
conditions like this however obviously
if a complaint was raised
because residents were concerned in the
area that there were more people living
than
than allowed then obviously is something
that we would investigate
there is the added element that if five
people were to occupy it
as well as being in a breach of the
planning condition it would actually
mean that an hmo license would be
required
for the property as well so they need a
license from private sector housing
so there are a couple of different
ramifications if actually that condition
is breached
so it is something that we would follow
up and again the fact that obviously it
is
in our view it's a it's a determinative
issue to put the condition on
we we you know we've asked for the
amendments to reduce it down to ensure
that the impact is
akin to a residential dwelling house in
this area
by restricting it to four people and
obviously if that is breached
you know what i'm i'm sure given the
number of objections that we would
certainly hear about it and we would
certainly
i had certainly is considered to be in
the public interest for us to follow
that up
by virtue of you know we wouldn't put
the condition on otherwise
thank you uh thank you ian councillor
joel bayford
thank you chair um i do understand the
concerns
um relating to hmos but
having listened to the officer's report
and
considering the location um the
proximity to public transport
um the conditions i feel
really that there is no potential harm
in the in this
application and i think i i probably
would like to support this
application thank you uh
thank you councillor bayford um
councillor wing
uh welcome thank you
i i do actually know the area quite well
and uh i've got i'm
i understand that we need we've got
desperate need for
for single persons properties across the
whole of planet
uh but i've got to share a lot of the
concerns that other people have got
you've got four people four people in
the room but you can't stop other
visitors and we could end up with
couples so there could be eight at the
property
there are already issues with parking
there's already issues with waste you
can see the recycling bin is actually at
the front of the property are they going
to share a recycling bin or are we going
to have four
four sets of uh recycling bins and four
sets of waste bins
uh i i also think we need to look at
some of these things in a ramsgate-wide
context because i believe we are
probably
the most densely populated uh
uh town in in the infanti and we really
need to review
what we're stuffing in a very small area
i was once quoted 95 percent of ramsgate
has already been built on i'm not sure
whether that's correct
uh i also have concerns that it will
trigger
other applications in for my hmos
and i i i believe there are already some
unofficial hmos on that street that
could do with some investigating so
i i'm i'm concerned you know i'm i'm the
same as councillor alban we've got a
desperate need for single persons
housing but i also have all these other
concerns
about about putting that type of housing
there
in addition is there it's a very small
property there to actually have four
adults living separately because it's
not a family unit it's four adults
living separately and i do remember my
days as a student
living in multiple occupancy
accommodation
what is the square footage per living
accommodation for each
individual uh and do we think does that
reach
uh is there any government guidance that
that we that it's
more than that or less than that
i know uh ian wishes to come back uh
perhaps you could answer
counselor wing on that as well ian uh
yes
so just to come back on on that point i
think this is it's
referenced in um there isn't a
planning uh there isn't planning uh
policy specifically to do with hmo sizes
but that is covered
science covered by private sector
housing and um
it is something that was looked at in
the consultation response that's in the
the report with regards to the size
um part of this in terms of the standard
of accommodation
and actually to pick up some of the
other points that a number of
councillors have made about
households i think just to make it quite
clear
this in the the premises is a household
the four people are living together
whilst
i appreciate what people are saying the
concern about it being that they're
living as
individuals these are not individual
households there are
one household there is a shared kitchen
there is a shared living room there are
bathrooms that are shared
therefore the waste collection will be
for one household
um and it's effectively these people
living as a household in there now i
appreciate that
everyone can recall but essentially if
they've lived in this type of
accommodation before
you know some people will keep
themselves themselves but at the same
time in terms of when you're considering
the impact of the property on the area
in terms of for example waste our view
is that it is not
significantly different to have a
material effect
on bin storage happening at the front of
the property for example
over and above an existing residential
property
um in terms of the actual size of the
rooms themselves
i think the smallest is that's allowed
is seven square meters and these rooms
are
not below that smallest standard to pick
up the point
about couples um
it sort of falls under the the remit of
the planning condition
so if there is a concern that the
couples would be staying at the property
again that isn't that eight people could
live there
um the condition would restrict that if
people
if there are visitors the property that
is no different from visitors to a
property on any other property on that
road
there is nothing to determine that there
will be more visitors to this property
than there would be to any other
household because individuals are
different individuals will have
different connections and people
will turn up there's no demonstrable
harm that we could attach to that
in order to determine or indeed refuse
the application
so i just think it's it's important to
remember that we can look at the issues
that are raised specifically by the
policy
but obviously in terms of concerns about
there being more people than the
restriction
would would put in place you know it is
not
something that i believe that we would
be in a position as the council to
defend on appeal
over and above looking at those very
specific criteria within the policy
thank you chair thank you and uh just to
comment i mean i i've touched on it
before the
you know the letters hmo um
always are a little bit misleading um
and again on this occasion i feel the
same but i think if
counselor wing is aware um
that there are other people living
illegally in belmont road yes i know i
live over here in margaret but i
do know belmont road and parking is
tight
um perhaps a word in the right direction
to those
that open the law so um
[Music]
councilor taylor
thank you chair um councillor keane and
councilwing actually did
um put the questions i was going to ask
but there's two other questions
um one is the virus whether whether
there be
more of a potential fire risk before
with the four people there and what was
put in place
and also um on the planning issue
obviously
we all um some of you may remember the
windham
avenue issue now obviously i know
as um obviously living sooner i said we
can't we
is it we're we're on this um planning
application tonight
but it we are in a similar situation i
think we're going to go down that road
if we're not careful
um i'm sure that officer livingston will
sort of
repeat my worry um and at the same time
as a counselor i can actually see where
counselor album is coming from
and um to be honest i don't like hmos
i shouldn't say it but i i don't like
hmos but at this time
i'm in a very awkward position and this
council could be put in an awkward
position as well
um the other question i would like to
say
ask as well counselors and you mentioned
about the bins and
it is an important situation because
um a place gets untidy
um if it's not um drawn out properly
will the beans
actually marked um what goes in where
because because these hmos i've seen in
the past they've become the right state
and they bring the area area down as
well
so we'll we'll we'll just be marked out
whether it be three bins you haven't
actually said how many bins there will
be
you see the normal household certainly a
red bin
a blue bin a large blue bin and a large
um black bin would this be the actual
case
please uh thank you counselor to say
uh um over to council oh sorry um
officer um thank you chair
the um so just to pick up the bin
storage point first
um so we we don't have any details
of the proposed uh bin
arrangement for the premises um as uh
cancer taylor has said
it's a it is a normal residential
property which this would be
effectively classed or for the purpose
of bin storage given again the numbers
that we're talking about
um it would be the same provision that
other households in that road
would have um i think in terms of
um what we could certainly do in terms
of putting informatives and our planning
commission
informative on the decision notice to
basically direct
uh the applicant to the council's
website which talks about what the
requirements are for
bins for any property um coming in and
again if there was
an issue that's caused by you know bins
at the front of the property
then it's certainly an issue that you
know can be raised to other
other channels uh not though through the
planning process and i think that's the
again the key point is that because
again this in terms of number of people
um is not over and above significantly
exceeding
what you would could potentially have in
a in a residential property along this
road
um it's it doesn't need specific
controls on it but again we would
certainly advise
and link to that that advice on the fire
safety point
um it's not something that is actually
covered through
planning legislation when it's actually
usually covered by other means in this
instance because it is people living in
a house there will be certain
requirements in terms of the the
landlord and what fire safety provisions
that they have to put in
under separate legislation so it's not
something that we would have to make
provision for
within the planning permission and it's
not not part of our considerations
that we have to make um and just to pick
up
the point about windham avenues so um
for some members will be familiar with
and others may not
but we have quite a lot of history with
regards to hmo applications
that have come to planning committee
over the last uh probably the last six
years
and two particular ones stand out one is
14 windham avenue
which was refused um in terms of
uh the impact on noise and disturbance
of neighboring properties for an hmo and
a residential street in cliftonville
as well as on the impact on uh parking
provision in the area
now that was for a larger hmo for i
think up to 13 people was what was
proposed because it was sort of it was
quite a large building
um that was approved on appeal and costs
were rewarded against the council
for the reasons for refuse to put
forward and that included
the fact that whilst parking was heavily
built up
it wasn't considered both that there
would be an exceedance of what
an existing property of that size would
would lead to
but also the sustainable location in
that instance
and proximity to the the main road in
cliftonville
um as well as that again it wasn't
considered that there was
noise and disturbance over and above
what you would get in a property
uh and you know it's found against the
council and costs awarded against us and
the same
pretty much the same occurred regards
the derby arms not too far away from
this site in fact
where again um the inspector considered
noise and disturbance as an issue uh and
it wasn't considered in that instance
that the noise
sensed from a 12-person hmo was worse
than a public house
which was what at that point members did
consider that it would have been
and again we got costs awarded against
us on that one so
it's very important that when looking at
hmos
all of any any potential concerns are
are couched in the material planning
considerations and on the basis of the
evidence
afforded which is obviously what we've
what we've done in terms of putting
forward the recommendation
thank you chair uh thank you and welcome
to
uh council scott i know a lot of people
quite
busy at the moment but thank you for
coming along um
i have got your point here councillor
wing i'll come to you in a moment
uh councillor heart
thank you chance i think most of my um
questions have been answered really
my concern is the number of people that
are going to be living there i know it's
restricted to four um but it it
i know the road as well so i mean it's i
think it's a shame to lose
uh single dwelling houses to go to an
hmo and a street like that
and i think it it and i understand what
um
mr livingston is saying with regards to
planning and
how we have to adhere to the rules and
guidelines
but um i think it's
it is an issue where i think we've got
to try and maintain
a family life you know in these sort of
streets we just can't turn every house
into an hmo
although i do agree that some people
need need to live in
an hmo um you know it's not a university
area it's not a
general and it's a very as as um
councillor wing said it's a very built
up area ramsgate
and um is it really necessary to have an
hmo in a road like that
that's my concern i am torn on this one
i must admit
uh thanks for that counselor if i may i
know it's very difficult but obviously
these applications
as you know coming um from whoever
and they have to be considered but i do
understand
uh the concerns that have been stated
here uh councillor curry
thank you chair um there there is a real
demand for this
type of household especially in this day
and age
and this hmo is certainly of a better
design
and development than many that i've seen
and therefore i am of the mind to agree
with the officer's recommendation
thank you chair thank you councillor
curry
um council sir wing you wish to come
[Music]
back
apologies just trying to get the right
button
you mentioned the dolby arms but i think
that is a hmo that is managed really
well and i think it's for particular
workers so the dolby arms
i don't believe has a particular impact
a negative impact on that area of
ramsgate
and it is stuck down at the end it's not
on a row of houses
one of the questions i sort of came into
my head as people were speaking were
we've got four adults living in a
property that i believe will spend more
time in their own rooms
which is not really a normal household
setup although young people will go to
their bedrooms
sometimes these houses are built on the
cheap
and i has there any been any
consideration about beefing up the uh
the the the insulation the sound
insulation insulation to
to minimize some of the effect on the
houses either side because it is a
terraced house
because adults can be quite noisy in
their own rooms
and uh i i well i can i can i can come
back and i'm part and actually that
that's it's a point actually that was
raised uh particularly regards the 14
windham avenue uh
appeal that i mentioned um the inspector
looked at
the position of in that instance the
staircase
in relation to other properties um
and it as as you actually if i if you
bear with me chair i just will present
my screen if you if you're permits
just to show you this layout again
um and i think that the key point here
is that because it is a terrorist
property um
what you have is you have a
sorry just wait for it to load up the
staircase that will be used
is gonna mirror the layout next door so
it's
it's you know in terms of where the the
chimney breasts are
so it means that in terms of where
people are moving around
coming in and going out um that will be
in this
in the same it won't be next to bedrooms
on the property either side in terms of
in the actual bedrooms themselves well
again that that comes down to the point
that
there's nothing to um to state that
there will be definitely
more disturbance than a family
living in this property there's nothing
to determine that that is exactly what
the inspector
made quite clear in the window avenue
appeal um
and and actually to touch on your point
counseling about about
management it is exactly that the
question here is about
management of the hmo it's not about the
principle of an hmo with four people
and therefore it is something that's not
that management isn't within the remit
of the planning system
to ensure that works is the principle of
the use which again in terms of the
impact of four people
in comparison to a family house is is
not significantly different to result in
material harm
for us in in our view an officer's view
uh to
refuse the application on that
particular policy and and there isn't
anything
that we can see that can be pointed to
to to create a reason for refusal and
and my concern is that
whilst i appreciate you know i
appreciate uh
counsellors concerns about this that the
change that's occurring
this is something that the you know the
planning system does allow and
yeah you know the agents email uh so the
email
the statement touched on this in in
other areas this would be a permitted
change it wouldn't be an application
that comes before
members um and the reason obviously why
specifically in fanet we put the article
4 on
in 10 years ago now was to look at that
issue of concentration because the very
specific issues that we have in fanat
with regards to proliferation of hmos
and
the issues that we were having around
those specific areas in cliftonville
um and that has given us a level of
control which does mean that we can for
example restrict it down to being four
people
rather than six but i think there is
only so far that we can go
before we are are trying to do something
that really
not in the planning system but also
inspectors will will simply not allow us
to do without
actual evidence that there's harm thank
you chair
thank you i'm going to bring in
cancer calm and cook and then i will
draw a line i think
a very good debate and i think um if i
may i know i don't
i mean very often as chair uh but i
think we have to listen to what at
what's been said by the officer and
obviously
um with what's in the report about this
application
possibly the implications and so forth
um
which has happened on as mentioned when
the avenue i remember the adobe arms
i do remember it as a pub but it didn't
change um
re-refused it uh and of course it did
cost the council quite a bit of money
by that but um i say they are my
thoughts and i
chair them eating and i'm not trying to
tell members what to do i dream of doing
that
um council coleman cook you wanted to
come in
yes thank you chair um
i'm inclined to agree with councillor
wing
who said we are in desperate need
of single people accommodation
it not everyone looking for housing
is married or in a relationship there
are an awful lot of people
in thanet single people that need
housing and i will be supporting
the officer's recommendation thank you
uh thank you for that council comic uh
just note here
from councillor taylor about council tax
um does the landlord pay i think
individuals pay i believe
and i fee and i know i'm coming back to
you in time
that's that's okay i'm i must admit i'm
not i'm not that familiar with this
um i i my own i can only speak to it
with regards to when um
when when when i lived in hmo about 10
years ago
and so i don't think it's particularly
relevant so i think it's probably best i
don't comment on
council tax for that okay
uh okay members um so i draw a line
under that i think we've had a good
debate there and
uh very interesting comments so um
the opposite recommendation is uh
approval and now i know we have um
a new member with us this afternoon what
i'm going to do is read your names out
once again and if you could you're for
the motion to approve please say so if
you're against
say against and if you're abstaining
please say so
so if i start with councillor coleman
cook
for council robin
chairman my heart is saying and i have
got one my heart is saying
uh re refused but my head is saying we
would lose on a pill
if we refuse so four thank you
councillor alban
uh councillor bayford for sure
councillor curry four
councilman
abstain
abstain i don't think counselor pat
moore
did arrive uh councillor
paul moore for councillor
scott i love staying on this one chair
okay fair comment uh councillor taylor
same viewers council album four thank
you council right
for and myself i'm for as
well um i will get confirmation but i
believe that has
been carried thank you katie
that has been carried that concludes the
public speaking members um i will call
upon
art to read out the remaining planning
applications
if a member wishes to reserve an
application
please give me a shout um which i will
make a note of
uh so i will hand over to the clark
please
katie yes um so the remaining
applications are agenda item 4b
saint peter's predicamentary um 117
canterbury road
west gate on c and ct8nw
and item 4c which is two
outcome close margate ct 9
3 jp thank you katie
are there any members who wish to debate
any of those items
chairman if i can come in i'd i think
we should debate item 4c
as it's a member of council staff and
i think it would be appropriate if we
didn't uh look at it
thank you chair okay so therefore
on that i will ask um and if you could
can you do that yes uh yes i can is it
worth just
running through the item not reserved
for public speaking just confirm that
first i can yes i always do that i think
members
realize that so the item uh
4b which is peter's professor never say
that
you know 117 canterbury road westgate
um if that is agreed we're not going to
debate could
have a proposal please
i'll propose that chair council second
please
members agree agreed
thank you thank you members
yeah so i will just present my screen
with regards to
the how come close application
so the site is outlined here in
red so going
in and looking at the property so it's
uh this property with the
the red car in front here so the
proposal
is for a uh single story rear extension
to the property
um so what you have this is the property
in the
the in the front uh sorry in the center
of the image
you have a walkway through uh which goes
through with
the garden of the property on the left
hand side
of this image but the actual property
oversales this this walkway
this is looking back towards the walkway
and you can see the main
body of the property here
uh and the other part of the property
turning to your right here
um so the proposal oh sorry just give
you an idea
again this is the view from much further
back looking towards the property
down the the route through
so what's proposed is effectively to
fill in
uh the sort of corner bit uh of
the uh of the garden of number two
so if i go back to the image this one
here it's to put the single story
extension
in this area here
uh so going through and showing the
elevation so this is the
the plan just showing the extent of the
extension
um you can see here actually they've
just shown where the public right of way
is the
the green is the notation of where the
extension
is so this is the rear elevation of the
property so you can see this is the
undercroft
uh underpass bit here and this is the
window so what will happen is
there'll be an extension that will be um
built in this area here
it's actually behind you can see
here it's actually on the right hand
side of the image um
so it's it's proposed to come out of the
the rear this is um this is actually
showing it through as a section so
this property that's here is actually
set further back in the image and i'll
go back to the images just to show you
that again um
again just to clarify so that is
where the extension is going to go it's
a relatively small extension um it's
flat roofing design there are various
extensions in and around the area um
that where this property has been
extended doesn't it it doesn't increase
the height
of the of a rear element over above what
you would expect from a single story
extension
and it's a bit of a quirk of the layout
of this particular
property um by virtue of where it is
that it even needs permission
at all because of where the highway is
because there's a public right of way
through because as you can see from the
next image
it's actually a it's a relatively small
extension
on the back of the property um but it is
um you know it hasn't
hasn't had any any particular concerns
raised through consultation
it's considered that it doesn't detract
from the character's appearance the area
substantively
and therefore it's recommended for
approval thank you chair
uh thank you ian i move that the
officer's recommendation
is adopted uh for approval could i
ask the vice chair to second please oh
second nature uh thank you council
common cook
do members wish to debate at all
see no names coming up but uh thank you
council robin for bringing that
notice as it as you say is a member of
the staff and
it's right to discuss okay as i have no
names here for uh speaking um
once again i'm going to come back to you
um
if you're in favor i think you know this
by now for
revenge you're against and if you're
abstaining please tell me
so through your names again uh council
common cook
for councillor orban for
councillor bayford four councillor curry
four
comes to right
that's the right four
myself i'm for it as well and
now that is carrie thank you uh katie
um members officers
that brings this meeting to a close
um